right at the beginning of the session the
hpc says goodbye to the high
performance computer there are things where
the european level is actually
irreplaceable and that is in the
acquisition and implementation of
expensive and large infrastructure
and high performance computing if you want
to play in the international league
that  cannot be achieved by a single
national state. there is
actually
no alternative to european cooperation, with
high-performance computers that are
necessary today in the field of
image analysis in the field of long-term
weather forecasts in the field of
materials science from a
molecular level to
a solid-state physics level
we have  made some important
progress today i won't tell you
everything the commissioner will
take over a part and will take over a
key aspect that we clarified today related to the legal basis
of
risen adviser has clearly d  Advocating that Reisen Europe's
specific
program be viewed as a
research
program and not a program that also
funds industry research